it's like if you think you've been
screwed you have right you are correct
you have been screwed and if you're
angry at government for letting that
happen you have an absolute right to
feel that way inequality is much more
than an economic inconvenience for the
people who who aren't well treated it
shreds the reciprocity Norms that make
social cohesion and democracy possible
and that's why our politics is so
screwed up today it is just an objective
fact that for most of the people in the
country certainly the bottom 80 or 90%
they have been exploited in a in a in a
in a really pretty terrible way for the
last 30 or 40 years and many many many
of them have lost faith in democracy and
government for reasonable reasons right
like that it's just a fact